Let's uh let's jump to this next uh
tweet because my friends we're gonna
have fun
Lauren Chen tweeted Twitter before Elon
versus Twitter after Elon the before
picture it's all women the after picture
it's all men yeah but there's like a
woman right there and there's like a
woman right there that might be a woman
right there I'm not sure but it looks
like two over here I think there's like
six guys there's like one two three lots
of soy boys four five six oh yeah is
that six one two three four five six soy
is palpable show that guy right there
you can smell and taste the soy just
imagine the stench okay so here's the
thing thing I tweeted Elon didn't fire
women he asked who wanted to work hard
LMFAO
because he put out this email where he
was like everybody we're all going to be
working really really hard
if you don't want to stay then take a
three-month Severance and get out yeah
and then uh these are the guys who
stayed late with Elon however there was
a fact check oh the fact check I guess
has been removed the bird watch thing
got taken down and it said that it's not
a before and after it's just the comms
team versus the engineering team which
also made me laugh because once again it
shows a very clear difference between
males and females on the issue the women
are subject oriented the males are are
object oriented but uh the truth is it
is this image of the of all these women
is from a tweet where a woman at Twitter
says I'm leaving on November 4th I'm
quitting so it quite literally is a
woman being like it's been fun I quit
here's a picture of my team and then the
picture of all the guys being like we're
staying until 2 A.M to do hard work yeah
my response to this tweet was uh the
women on the left better learn to code
automatically uh and and then you you do
see a big clear kind of difference and
obviously there are different teams and
to answer your question Mary
specifically the misinformation team is
gone but the moderation team is still
there so there are a lot of people who
have different kind of political belief
systems that are aligned usually with
their genders we we saw and and they're
kind of uh relationships we saw during
these latest midterms that one of the
biggest voting blocs that voted for the
Democrats were women that didn't have a
partner and those were people that came
out and voted more than they previously
have before so so clearly there is a big
kind of political shift and difference
between these two pictures as well and I
think it's pretty clear to to see the
difference
chicks to their own devices clearly
leads to disaster every time
oh man I bet they feel aggrieved right
now aggrieved I did a segment on this I
was talking about how um
56 of women prefer to be in the
workforce according to Gallup
56 that's actually not that many yeah
exactly and there were like an all-time
high 56 I'm like you're telling me that
half of women don't want to be at work
plus they're women the women who report
that they want to be in the workforce
but actually don't
that's probably a huge percentage as
well
socially driven subject-oriented Etc
there's going to be a lot of women who
are like I is it bogus young again
the cat is at the studio door yelling
because should I let him in no
absolutely not why because woke me up at
seven o'clock in the morning I'm pissed
at him and he is it's terrorist cat
hungry that's what I'm talking about
he's a cat
that is and taxoplasmosis is real and I
just don't get along with that cat I
have toxic we have super nice no he's
not he loves it absolutely not we all
love him absolutely yeah anyway about
these women yeah oh yeah I was just
wondering also like cat ladies thank you
exoplasmosis a real thing I want to know
how many mothers uh report wanting to
stay in the workforce it's probably an
even lower number once they've started
working I don't know it's funny because
uh we did a segment on this and The
Young Turks did a segment mocking me
saying like you know I said I said of of
the women that probably don't want I
can't remember exactly what I said I
said they're probably some women
somewhere who say they want to work but
don't and I was like very vague with it
and I was like they're going to be
unhappy if they don't have families and
then The Young Turks to this huge
segment where they were like Tim Poole
thinks women want to be stay-at-home
wives or whatever and I'm like yo Gallup
says they do like as half of women do
but the reason I bring that up is
because
before covet the amount of men that were
staying at home stay-at-home dads one to
five percent
that's ridiculously low relative to
women so guys want to be out in the
workforce women prefer to be at home
working at home because it's this is the
craziest thing to me this idea that like
taking care of a house and kids doesn't
work
all of a sudden now it's like do you
want to be at work or stay at home it's
like well they're both work you know
because it's only work if it benefits
some third-party conglomerate basically
right yeah just a quick observation
about this this picture now that I'm
looking at it it really
it represents a different dimension
According to which musk is challenging
the system because there's the Free
Speech Dimension we're talking about but
also like when you really think about
how major corporations are structured
it's actually borderline illegal to have
a corporation that's set up to maximize
efficiency and output
in California it's borderline illegal
even at a national level it is illegal
in California now it's illegal but it
goes to show on one hand you can look at
the left side of the picture and say
probably useless it's maybe a you know
the project it's the the project manager
uh Massacre you could call it but but on
the other hand there's so many useless
people that companies are somewhat
obliged to hire in order to Shield
themselves from a whole range of legal
liabilities that have been sort of built
into the Nexus between the
corporate economic structure and the
legal structure and so there's this
weird sort of
Phantom utility to having all of this
dead weight in a company simply as legal
protection and political protection from
precisely these third-party NGO ADL type
rackets that exist to shake down your
company yeah it's like an artificially
inflated HR department it's exactly what
it is and a lot of people a lot of these
people don't work we saw it from The
Tick Tock videos they're like we're
going for our morning mimosas and then
we're going to support the
African-American owned business yeah
vegan restaurant downstairs that caters
for us all the Caterers are supposed to
be there for us but the office is empty
wonder why you want to pull this up yeah
yeah so this is uh
I don't want to play it too loud a tale
of two different realities check out
this video
two guys on the right I don't know I
don't know
it's an oil rig they're just gonna add
pipe or take pipe away as it goes down
oh that's what they're doing yeah that's
what the guys do it looks like they're
really good at it look at that they're
covered in in filth of some sort the
guys
and on the left it's a woman who's
talking about going to her little booth
and getting smoothies and eating her
chicory boards and having her wines and
living a yuppie lifestyle and having her
little meditation food the world on the
left is only possible because of the
world
yay we have to play football
oh oh now I should get her safe space
look at that this is my farting room I
go in there and I
have yoga mats uh yeah
yeah yo it's so
disgusting absolutely seeing what these
companies are and I've seen them
firsthand I've been to Google HQ but
I've been I've been there San Francisco
and New York offices they're LA offices
it is absolutely insane it is it is
daycare I can't even begin to describe
it having having come from a life where
I've had look at that wine dispenser
like a red wine dispenser for for a
plastic couple these guys oh cool they
got the corn working the oil rig on the
roof wow on the roof get better how what
can we do to get all these people fired
from their jobs
I think Elon just get them pregnant get
them pregnant well no no they're just
gonna go get abortions
paid for it by Eli musk Elon Musk is
allowing employees to get paid abortions
and it's paying for their travel so Elon
Musk still is a part of this yeah he's
funding it yes Elon Musk is funding his
employees to go out of state to get
abortions that's amazing so again I mean
it's a cool check on that yeah right now
fact Checker Tesla right yeah Tesla
specifically but this is probably going
to be the same women's ability this is
probably also going to be the same
policy in California because in
California it's probably mandated by law
women's ability to create and sustain
life definitely makes them weaker in the
workforce and uh you either have
policies like that or you're gonna hire
women less and you wonder also how much
what function these project managers
types are really serving there's the
sort of Legal Shield then there's also
the morale question you know maybe
they're just kind of giving those guys
on the right side of the picture
something something to look at after a
hard four hour coding session oh no hold
on hold on that that was inappropriate
Darren for our coding session these
people don't code
and four hours is way too much time for
them these are these are like they might
break a nail no no I'm talking about the
right side of the picture with all of
the engineer guys maybe the project
managers are there for morale they're
like depends that's so true yeah you
know that that because they don't have
lives to come home to and those guys on
the right they wouldn't be able to do
all that hard piping work if it wasn't
further you see the Twitter employee the
project managers go there for the
smoothies but the project managers are
the smoothies for the Coatings
that's so awesome the way the way I was
describing it earlier is that um the
most important role in my opinion is the
stay-at-home mom or stay-at-home Dad if
Dad wants if Dad's doing it but the
person who's actually protecting and
taking care of the family because if a
guy were to go out and fight a bear with
his with his own hands and and take it
down for the question is for what
purpose
he's an opportunity if he has no family
he has no one to protect so what's the
point of fighting the bear if he's able
to just take care of himself he can eat
Badger rabbit and whatever else he
wouldn't be able to actually eat the
bear so the great conquests of the man
who's going out and working hard is only
for the family and if there's no one
there to actually help protect his
family then what's the point yeah
raising the family is the most important
job you could have in our society or who
else is going to be raising them but
they make it disrespectful yeah so like
when I say something like half of women
would prefer to be at home the left gets
offended by it how dare you we would be
better served working fifty thousand
dollar a year jobs for some
multi-millionaire in his Factory okay
okay I guess I don't think so I think
you'd be better served raising kids and
having a family and teaching human
beings to exist that's not what the
state and Central controllers want they
want a bigger tax base they want a
bigger base of sheep they want people
that don't get to raise their children
so the indoctrination Center get to
raise them so the big social Tech media
platforms get to raise them so the
televisions the boob tubes gets to raise
them and when of course you have
children raised by the state you have
better sheep and that's of course what
they're also looking for in my opinion
better that you don't have children at
all though you're just the last of your
line of progeny I disagree especially
with the upcoming population collapse
that's going to be coming and destroying
and wreaking havoc on civilization
I'm just saying I think the corporation
should have should be having children no
I do too I'm saying the corporations
would rather you not have children at
all than indoctrinate your children oh
well yeah let's double for them thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time